when you watch a major motion picture
you'd never imagine that a huge
production would make any last-minute
decisions or if they did it would surely
be over something small not something
that could drastically change the movie
forever but really the opposite is true
some of your favorite films were within
an inch of turning out terrible if it
wasn't for a last-second change that
made these movies into what they are
today Toy Story before Toy Story became
a classic of computer animation it was
almost a mean-spirited cartoon about a
jerky cowboy doll that everyone hated
Jeffrey Katzenberg Disney's CEO at the
time had wanted this cartoon in a new
medium to be as edgy as possible
eager to please the Pixar folks push the
meanness to the max and hoped it was
going in the right direction when they
screen the first part of the film no one
could believe the results it was just a
story about mean hateful toys there was
no fun and nothing lovable in this
version woody intentionally tosses buzz
out the window then the toys revolt
against him and throw him out the window
to his own doom even director John
Lasseter couldn't believe how bad it was
I was pretty much embarrassed with what
was on the screen the result the execs
wanted Lasseter to fire a bunch of
people and start animating under
Disney's direct supervision he refused
and asked for two weeks to make it work
Disney allowed it and after working all
hours and disregarding all the previous
notes the Pixar team was able to present
enough of the revised Toy Story to keep
their jobs and keep going with the film
in the end the story was completely
retooled and became the wonderful movie
we all loved today Zootopia in its
original form Zootopia hardly resembled
the film we know now first of all Judy
Hopps wasn't the main character plus all
the Predators had to wear shock collars
around their necks for their whole lives
if that sounds unpleasant don't worry
the Zootopia filmmakers agreed in the
original script once predators got to a
certain age they'd have to put on their
taming collars for the first time
watching this happy little bear realized
he'll never be free again as
heartbreaking though Disney doesn't
usually shy away from heartbreak the
filmmakers eventually felt the overall
Taming concept made the movie too dark
and unappealing
so they revamped the entire script made
Judy the main character and through
those collars in the idea garbage
American Beauty before winning five
Academy Awards American Beauty nearly
had a different
that may have kept it out of the Oscars
altogether in the first draft of the
script the story is book ended by a
court trial in which Lester's daughter
Jane and her boyfriend Ricky are accused
of shooting Lester the trial uses the
tape they made where Jane says she'd
like Ricky to get rid of her dad as the
proof the film ends with Ricky and Jane
getting wrongfully convicted and sent to
jail in the end a last-minute edit came
to the rescue
we shot all that stuff but luckily Sam
you know in editing sort of took it out
screenwriter Alan Ball agreed with the
change feeling that the ending was too
depressing that might sound strange for
a film that already ends with the main
character getting shot but the innocent
teens taking the blame was a step too
far plus it took away from Lester's main
story so the wraparound was cut and
Ricky and Jane got to go free Shrek the
character of Shrek went through a lot of
changes before we ended up with the
Scottish ogre with a heart of gold
originally mike myers recorded most of
his lines in a canadian accent it was
basically meyers own voice with a bit of
exaggeration but the actor felt it
wasn't working right
inspired by the upper-class English
accent John Lithgow used for Lord
Farquaad Myers felt Shrek should have a
more working-class sound
he ended up settling on Scottish and
insisted on redoing all the lines with
his new idea look there's blood nut the
flatulent you can guess what he's famous
for all right now I know you make a
Nissen
unfortunately the animators had already
finished a third of the film and the new
voice required a ton of changes in fact
Myers choice to go Scottish cost the
film at least four million dollars
clerks Kevin Smith made a big splash
with his independent film debut clerks a
black and white comedy about two aimless
men working at a convenience store
clerks set up characters that Smith
would return to for years to come part
of what makes clerks great was its
casual comedic dialogue and
slice-of-life tone that all could have
been ruined by the original ending
originally Dante one of the quick stop
workers gets shot in a robbery and the
film ends right after that
Brian O'Halloran the actor who played
Dante said I hated that ending I just
thought it was too quick of a twist as
it turned out Smith wasn't married to
that finale either he shot it mostly
because he wasn't sure what to do to in
the movie luckily he agreed with
O'Halloran and went with the non tragic
ending where the store simply closes for
the evening and life goes on
Terminator 2 the ending of Terminator 2
is literally the most metal ending of
all time
a robot gets lowered into a vat of
molten metal so imagine if after that
the movie cuts to a bright blue sky over
a playground where granny Sarah Connor
is tying her cute little grandchild
shoes that's originally how director
James Cameron wanted it to end in that
Indian Judgment Day never happened John
Connor is a senator and Sarah is an old
lady with a drinking problem thankfully
Cameron realized that this Indian was
completely out of tune with the rest of
the film and would have ruined any
chances for sequels or maybe he finally
saw the wisdom in the terminators own
words it has to end here now it was
totally about the sequels thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]